okay guys I'm going to do operation
Hellas terror
let's do this just water it sounds like
so Jonah three difficulties easy
moderate or difficult so to deploy
hopefully there's like a big difference
between them cuz I just a difficult buck
and hardship my my templates getting har
suggest a hacker working for the
resistance it has no capability in the
Advent network and try to pull some of
their data from a terminal in this area
unfortunately the aliens were quick to
eliminate the operative but as far as we
can tell the data is critical to the
aliens latest operation yeah you need to
recover what we can eliminate all enemy
contacts and secure the area
that's a chase ss the network before
they have time to lock down the
connection
menace 1 5 this is Avenger the access
point we're after is just ahead [ __ ]
far to secure the area expect hostile
resistance and
I don't want him getting hurt so I'm
going to go right fucking-a here moving
out okay
yeah I can just suck and you can go
right there
because I'll be there yeah you're not
really already there but okay Kenna
there's nothing looks ready to smash
something [ __ ] is that I'm in suit maybe
something I can't handle our atmosphere
those emissions could be toxic I advise
caution
commander [ __ ] ass ass
I guess anything over there I guess not
[ __ ] and location confirmed Charlie like
Chacho stop [ __ ] lay down
[ __ ] is that okay can you get up there
now this is the spot I want to bei copy
that how's it gonna get over there thank
God
I don't know what the [ __ ] that is a lot
of [ __ ] over though
[ __ ] good copy moving on target
I like shet app yes movin out [ __ ]
raid protocol not him the other one
there we go
she better get your dick sucked
are we the ho [ __ ] if I saved a nation s
1 I should save an H for this [ __ ] cuz
you shoot it Bob what the [ __ ] kind of
gonna is he half
I just taking Scotch out tonight yeah
huh
target neutralized I wonder I don't know
what do Stephanie love that Birnam
I can't crispy assuming come again [ __ ]
ragout we shred some of that [ __ ] we
won't do much and I don't want to
[ __ ] die so oh okay well stronger
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] face about that that's
great what's happening now we all saw
that thing go down now what the hell is
it doing no it's up in [ __ ] gay
[ __ ] [ __ ]
what's it done [ __ ] it like psychic [ __ ]
watch out there ah the specialist take
out yeah
okay this is the one that's the [ __ ]
run in so blow it out
[ __ ] overwatch for sure moving to
overwatch what is that oh there's like
acid or something on the ground
yeah it's acid [ __ ]
that affirmative
okay you go in there papa
copy that I'm Texas located nearly the
name commander we have confirmation of
the exposed access point
ten-four
[ __ ] weird oh [ __ ]
double time double time Australian can't
tell keep that should be shot [ __ ]
reinforcements inbound
I killed him one shot yeah target
disabled on overwatch step it off
confirmed
going on it and it goes
playing [ __ ] fried Advent forces on
the ground
mmm
hostile target down and
seabird right puck
[ __ ] dead [ __ ]
target eliminated attempting
infiltration let's say a baby
[Music]
we're in we've confirmed successful
acquisition of the Advent Files
eliminate any remaining hostels in the
area
Roger that you got a pattern hey you
never know that target neutralized oh
[ __ ]
no need to ask twice [ __ ] jump off
the belt and to climb up another bill
that suck oh there's still that weird
like left content it's a [ __ ] flowing
guy wearing
he's Darius he's got a nasty bite oh my
possessions been compromised don't hit
the ground don't hit the ground don't
hit the ground what the [ __ ] how they
die so quickly okay Beckett
[ __ ] who knows oh my god so stop Cal my
eyes I beg ya [ __ ] he's done
no maybe is not ni right now try /m
because I would definitely get him right
[ __ ] I just cut that [ __ ] run all the
way over there as I slice up Oh get your
[ __ ] miss you dick domestic hey Sam
Jeff [ __ ] [ __ ] chill confirmed
they're on the move
should I show you in a minute [ __ ]
mark them I think we have an alien here
one more holy [ __ ] oh you never know you
never know it's gotta be [ __ ] gold
and so get it together this past year
just do eat protocol who's [ __ ] himself
No and then this guy should [ __ ] a
run away that's affirmative
that's right get the [ __ ] out
oh [ __ ] moving to position like I pop
this sucker who Marcia oh how are you
still [ __ ] alive
I just [ __ ] cover at the window
[Music]
[ __ ] pop this [ __ ] hostile
terminated
flash gosh [ __ ]
you know he got some - it's down this
one might be carrying something that it
I've got it
status confirmed yeah hostels are down
in the area is secure spill one person
specialist got operation hell's terribly
got now it's time for me to eat my
shrimp okay it's just time for me to get
my shrimp thanks for watching y'all back
out